[Musique]
les médias les gouvernements et les
entreprises travaillent de concert pour
en arriver à une vaccination de masse
qui va mener à la dépopulation l'espèce
humaine
le saviez vous c'est en somme ce
qu'affirme cette publication partager
des milliers de fois depuis le début du
mois de mai intitulé ne vous faites pas
dépister ce message d'abord publié par
le site la table ronde connu pour son
penchant pour la désinformation a été
abondamment copier coller dans les
réseaux sociaux l'auteur du message
serait un policier dont l'identité n'est
jamais dévoilées en gros le message
exhorte les gens à ne pas se faire
dépister
parce que les tests ne seraient pas
fiables selon cette publication et qu'il
produirait c'est est intentionnellement
un taux élevé de faux positifs des tests
positifs qui avoisinerait les 90 pour ça
mais petit problème au québec et en
france les taux positifs à la copie 2009
avoisinerait plutôt 12% à la mi mai
parmi la kyrielle d'information fausse
ou non fondées se trouve aussi dans ce
texte
l'explication de l'origine du terme
coville 19 aux prétendants cette
publication que cauvin 19 signifie
surtout aux vaccinations identity donc
certificat d'identification de vaccins
et le 19 mai représenteraient les
premières et 9e lettres de l'alphabet à
et et high key l'abréviation d'artichaut
intelligence ou intelligence
artificielle en anglais ce nom
découlerait d'un plan international
d'asservissement et de réduction des
populations élaboré depuis des dizaines
d'années en réalité le virus à l'origine
de la maladie kobe 19 s'appelle en fait
coronavirus 2 du syndrome respiratoire
aigu sévère sras skov 2 et son nom a été
choisi par le comité international de
taxonomie des virus le 11 février
dernier
ce comité a choisi ce nom parce que le
virus est génétiquement apparentée au
corona des russes responsables de la
flambée de strass en 2003 remet ça
officiellement baptisé la maladie causée
par le virus rachkov 2 covey 19 pour qu
une avarice 10 maladie accorda virus
l'année d'apparition du virus dans la
ville de wuhan en chine
pour plus de détails sur ce dossier qui
contient un paquet d'informations
trompeuses
consultez l'article de mon collègue
nicolas de rosa sur notre page web ou
consulter leur cet article sur notre
groupe facebook n'oublie pas notre
émission diffusée les samedis et
dimanches souricière dit allez salut
[Musique]